inundaciones masivas y deslizamientos de
tierra peligrosos causados por el ciclón
Gabriel han obligado a miles a evacuar
en la isla norte de Nueva Zelanda luego
de que el Primer Ministro chriskins
declarara el estado de emergencia por
tercera vez en la historia del país la
gente estará al tanto de que se ha
declarado en estado de emergencia
nacional Y eso significa de Que
estaremos poniendo todo en nuestra parte
para asegurarnos de que estamos
brindando el mayor apoyo posible a la
respuesta quiero reconocer la situación
en la que los neozelandeses se han
estado despertando esta mañana muchas
familias desplazadas muchos hogares sin
electricidad daños extensos en todo el
país nos tomará un poco de tiempo
entender exactamente lo que sucedió el
ciclón azotó en la isla norte de Nueva
Zelanda el domingo y se espera que se
mueva hacia el sur Durante los próximos
días si bien el país ha superado lo peor
Se esperan más lluvias y fuertes vientos
en los próximos días con más de 200.000
personas a oscuras
Esto no se compara con nada Es
simplemente exagerado realmente como los
truenos Los Relámpagos y todo anoche fue
Simplemente horrible pero con la
devastación solo te dan ganas de llorar
para ser honesto es muy molesto
hipkins ha prometido un paquete de ayuda
de 11.5 millones de dólares
neozelandeses casi 7 millones de euros
para ayudar en los esfuerzos de
recuperación